the attack happened as israel celebrated
74 years of independence this time in
aladd an ultra-orthodox city in the
centre of the country ilad is very close
to the occupied west bank we do not
have full indication
if it's a one terrorist or more we are
conducting a
chase after him
we have a helicopter with us and we are
setting roadblocks in order to catch him
residents came out to protest in the
aftermath it's the latest in a series of
attacks carried out by individuals
across israel which has left at least 14
israelis dead a spokesperson for hamas
reacted by saying these attacks were the
result of israel's occupation of
palestinians u.n middle east envoy
torvenisland tweeted saying he was
appalled by the attack and that it was
deplorable that hamas and others
continue to glorify and encourage such
acts
israeli media replayed a clip from hamas
leader in gaza yahya sinwa who in a
fiery speech last week called on
palestinians to protect the al-aqsa
mosque compound referring to the recent
escalations at the site by the entry of
jewish religious ultranationalists and
encouraging individual attacks
defence minister benny ganz met with the
military chief of staff and the israeli
prime minister nathalie bennett was
being updated on the situation the
border crossings from gaza and the
occupied west bank had been closed since
tuesday afternoon due to memorial day
and independence day in what is standard
procedure doing events like these in
israel the west bank closure has now
been extended until sunday as a result
of this attack stephanie decker
al-jazeera west jerusalem